go down to the boardwalk go down to the
county fairs in town with a nickel get
yourself some time old-ass candy I'm
thinking something dusty a nice pie
seeing lots of licorice which I don't
lawyer I feel like their lives consisted
of taffy and butterscotch it's just
gonna be fruit you're just gonna hand us
an apple ah the good old fashioned
Charleston chew
cuz the Charleston was probably the new
latest dance move oh they smell good
this was a whole family's candy ah has a
good visual that oh great
alright Charleston now going on dude
like this is what you give your kid to
make him shut up that's like a Snickers
but no nuts or caramel you can't eat
this in less than 24 hours the Roaring
Twenties this tastes like sin oh wow
this guy looks high as hell and I did
not want to be dentist in the 20s it
makes me feel like it's gonna slow me
down and like any big how are you
supposed to eat this this is that guy he
slaps them around the faces off like
actually not that bad looks like a
Stretch Armstrong there's this shoe that
they're talking about dad chew I think
it's pretty clear the caramel found it
placement they put it inside of candy
bar yeah I'm not made at its own thing
see why this one did not stand the test
of time sky bar each little section is
its own flavor for different types
oh wait that you got caramel vanilla
peanut and fudge what depression I mean
right so I was hoping they'd all be
mixed together and now I'm really
disappointed that each one is a
different one
oh yeah you could share with your
friends number a good chocolate caramel
is pretty crappy the fudge is pretty
good
oh my battle they all taste the same
that fun is gone oh it's also very this
is not look like vanilla huh
they're all the same consumer thank you
I would say this sky bar is my favorite
so far
it's got the most going on for it candy
coated peanuts
well this looks like ibuprofen but it
just doesn't look like it should be
candy like baked beans is with barbecue
they're like oh my god oh I'm not
supposed to fight I know it
oh my tooth I like them
this is a good - hi sugar - peanut ratio
just like Eminem without the chocolate I
think they're weird
I always but the kind of good wid big
hunk oh yeah this is Mike hi handing the
big hunk get off with a snack attack
place bar firmly in one hand then smack
your big hunk on a hard surface one two
three oh you know the housewives are
kind of like sexually repressed and they
just need to be like yeah there's like
Lucky Charms
oh this flavor of this toffee looks
pretty good though new best one Kenny
has come a long way yeah I was expecting
it to taste terrible and have no flavor
but it is actually pretty good I think
in the olden days candy worked for it
you got the reward when you earned it we
have like some sour punch straws and
Reese's now hey Eddie ready to go to the
Box social good I got a pull on the
mattefy these petunias are for you also
got milk